ó
estou aqui para te dizer que vai vencer
e vai reclamar do governo faça o que
fizer isso vai acontecer mas não que
sustente pensa que é o sonho cheio de
riscos aventuras surpresas
e como em todos os sonhos haverá um dia
irá recordar e não faz mal o que torna a
vida é tão valiosa é o fato de ela ter
um fim não durar por exemplo
agora sei que o tempo é sorte por isso
no último disco outras coisas que não
sejam tentar ser feliz
o tempero de um sonho com o sal da vida
ao valer muito curioso
e puderam mostrar pra ser adquirido nos
doem
um grande pedaço que não conosco e o
sonho dos outros porque tá contágio
nosso
o que forma poderíamos sonhar
olá amigos
a hola muito votar nós estamos aqui hoje
para desafiar a alcançarem os vossos
sonhos histórias que ouvimos hoje falar
só sobre pessoas que nunca nunca
existiram sinhá joão finanças internas
nasceu com paralisia cerebral e desde
sempre a sociedade tentou por várias
vezes com o carro lado e sistema de
ensino trabalho até nas relações
pessoais
joão fernando será considerada não
insistir em usar tudo joão nunca eu
tenho 36 anos numa luta franzinha
retirar vários cursos e ser hoje uma das
pessoas mais influentes e interessadas
nós conhecemos ainda hoje o joão não
existe concretizar o seu sonho o sonho
de ser feliz e nós perguntamos por que é
seco sumiram em que tal como joão as
pessoas da nossa casa sabem muito mais
publicidade que nós eu acho os sonhos
são possíveis e verão os amigos juntos
é por isso que na nossa casa somos
família fazemos questão que seja isso
mesmo uma casa na nossa casa entre essa
mesmo é valorizar os que nos ama fazer
os outros fluídos também e para isso é
fácil basta aceitaria mas de outras
pessoas exatamente como elas são mais
importante é amar um de nós próprios
exatamente com os sons irmão ainda 88
anos há três anos ter retirado hoje iraí
desde então sempre que parecem público
faz questão já para essa partida ainda
participou do nosso nossa
são do projeto americano o hiv nesse
projeto ele ainda teve a oportunidade de
falar sobre as suas fragilidades sobre
as suas inseguranças conheceu as e
percebi o quanto este afetavam a sua
vida quando a imprensa escrita por mim
ou sua foto em olinda por usinas
próprias do ranking ela ela fica
distribuída uma cópia no jornal e linda
ganhou uma nova visão sobre si mesmo é
possível que não só o seu jorge que
definem e linda é linda é uma pessoa
alegre divertida que tem muito mal feito
pela manhã mas que adora brincar
excellence adora passear e
principalmente dormir a sesta é sua
fragilidade está muito longe de definir
o destino de pensar também nas nossas
próprias inseguranças na nossa luta
viária em corresponder aos padrões do
senado
todos os dias ao reino unido como falar
com estar com um estilo até nos dizem
que quem nós sabemos do estado
isso nós fugirmos vez dos padrões somos
muitas vezes julgados ridicularizados e
muitas vezes com a luz para as pessoas
da nossa casa acreditam que para nós
temos fluídos em aceitar é necessário
aceitar a diferença de coração aberto é
necessário aceitar as pessoas como elas
são e acreditem isso é muito mais fácil
e salva-vidas documentos porque estamos
a falar de amor amor incondicional
não poderíamos deixar de falar do nosso
companheiro luta pelo menos no nosso
madrinha e acreditem o vadinho mestre
das dicas da felicidade porque eu tenho
essa capacidade inata nos chamar
simplesmente sermos nós próprios podemos
estar despenteados que tenhamos tarde
chama podemos de testar ganhou onze
renovado e vai sempre cumprimentarmos
como se nós fôssemos evitou-se é a noção
do nosso melhor amigo
foi uma estratégia usava e os seus
filhos estão sim efetivamente provado
vale ou melhor vida melhor assumiram e
para a missão na nossa casa e lá um uso
muito os nossos netos e até amanhã a
razão de haver uma aproximação com o irã
foi o aumento vale chega muitas vezes
que os que mais ninguém com sexo você
chegar e ler o funcionário do ano
trabalha 24 horas o 24horas eu não tem
férias e não recebe salário e como podem
ver nessa imagem pois muito em bangui
nesta apresentação
eu estava muito cansado ambos do amanhã
quando usada uma idéia do novo foi
invadida na torre realizamos um estudo
altamente enfim nós fizemos uma
experiência e colocar um gorro a passear
na praia com e sem variam e depois vamos
contar de forma minuciosa o número de
abordagens por parte do sexo feminino
para mostrar para mostrar resultados
temos aqui um gráfico como podemos ver
sem vadio ver mulheres engordaram mais
valentes com vale foram 20 as mulheres o
estudo é muito claro as conclusões não é
este o elmer conclusivo o vazio o bahia
para lhes fazer mais saudáveis mais
alegres torna mais vírus
no entanto nem tudo são rosas e para
além do cozinheiro xixizinho e é óbvio
que o vazio no gesso é processar alguém
aqui convencido é que ele tem é culpa do
bahia eu era tamanho grande culpado no
já não responsável estamos aqui hoje
chama e é um dos momentos principais na
multiplicação na sociedade e por para
nós
a felicidade só faz sentido quando
partilhada aquilo que realmente nós
criamos aquela chega ao maior número de
pessoas
então vocês vão nos ajudar a realizar
esta missão cuja voz alemão perdendo mas
já tem aqui o meu brilho as mensagens
sim mensagem nova
já está há uma mensagem nova sim e agora
vão escrever gosto muito do que nós
muito elevado por favor faça um de nós
muito insuficiente já está lá há aí nós
agora vocês vão enviar esta mensagem
pelo menos uma pessoa da nossa lista
podem enviar as suas tona mas tem o seu
valor mas podem enviar a mensagem é uma
pessoa da minha família eu tô com as 40
tá já está a faltar agora o plano de
fazer é que vamos fazer contas
então se estamos aqui 500 pessoas e se
cada um de nós enviou a mensagem pelo
menos é uma pessoa
fizemos mais bonitas pessoas não querem
mais felizes e pelas caras que nós fomos
vendo em vocês podem enviar essa
mensagem vai ficar no fluido
então quando os 500 pessoas e e mais as
500 pessoas foram mensagens
pra mim meus amigos fizemos mais mil
pessoas 21
e é isso mesmo
e é isso mesmo que nós queremos
multiplicar essa cidade vindo a falar em
um dos braços dos beijinhos nos rostos
de fazemos questão de usar e dizer às
pessoas que importam para nós servimos
tamanho das novas tecnologias pode
passar a mensagem a quem nem sempre está
ao nosso lado
a luz você já fazem parte da união
pessoas que nos conhece do governador
que eu passei no ano sei onde a nossa
lang dela de bengala no ranking bom não
é só ela e alguém nesta sala não tenha
visto neste vídeo vamos sair
imediatamente em lua nova é estes vídeos
ea nossa primeira luta e sua energia
turno não só para nos divertirmos
divertir nos agrada mas existem
propósito de motivos vai mais novas e o
primeiro podemos repente apontar e
realmente é a forma mais eficaz de
chegar à família centro como estamos
fotografias ou vídeos e mensagens
mentalize e até com cinemas família
janeiro quando conquistaram homem zeni
porque não passou apaixono junho em
belém pa
e é por esse produto emite que acham que
sempre que o facebook foi abaixo foi por
nossa causa mesmo assim um lugar por uma
autoestima
imaginem vocês fazem um vinho e mostram
dez pessoas e elas dizem está claro
agora transporta em si para milhares de
mensagens de apoio e vão conhecimento e
oems uma pessoa a entrar na nossa casa
achavam e morrendo os utentes chegou a
ser conhecidos na rua e acreditem até já
deram autógrafos termos de casa nair que
mora conosco e que estão no estrangeiro
teve 120 minutos em directo na televisão
e já deu mais de dez entrevistas e
durante uma dessas entrevistas os filhos
vieram de férias para visitar a mãe
entraram no ar e foi mãe dona não ir aos
cuba não posso dar uma entrevista
lá é através destes o nome conseguimos
dar voz a quem muitas vezes já aprendeu
as lições já chegaram muito bem mais
longe do sonho os excluídos uma
sociedade e gravadora capaz de
reconhecer o papel eo estatuto do idoso
ajudando a defender a idéia de
envelhecimento como um problema da
sociedade mas sim como um potencial como
uma história de desenvolvimento e acima
de tudo como uma história de sucesso e
nem a participação dos 11 novos nos
meios de comunicação social não
contribui só para a melhoria da
qualidade vida no assim uma hora mas
contribui para tutores um dia possam
viver voz e sem investimento e sem
qualquer tipo de conceito para que um
dia possa também devem galã sem qualquer
diz que conceito por isso nós esqueças
campanhas mesmo estiver medo sony a sony
na mesma seringa viagens nossos eventos
e tempera o teu sonho com salva a minha
a temperatura contudo faz lhes vivia tão
intensamente que não haja espaço para
mais nada que não é tua felicidade
a idéia aqui que achamos que merece
partilhada e e pública precisa me ver
nina da brigada